[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy who's
like a Hydra agent because I always aim
for the sky the Daisy
anyway agents of shield is back with its
second episode of season 7 and the
time-traveling adventure has a lot to
unpack from it throughout this video
we're gonna be breaking down the latest
entry discussing what's going on and
giving our theories for the future there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
show yet then I highly recommend that
you turn off now please drop a thumbs up
if you enjoy the video and make sure you
subscribe for breakdowns on the season
week-by-week without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
agents of shield season 7 episode 2 okay
so we open in the midst of last week's
events in case you missed it the chronic
comms are trying to wipe out shield and
they realize that the best way to do
that is to in fact destroy Hydra so
therefore they would never need to be
created their target is Wilfred Malik
the father of Gideon Malick who he
learned was the head of the organization
earlier in the series Malick was
instrumental to some of the events in
the Avengers and even helped to give the
go-ahead to nuke New York so not the
best guy but they have to save Hydra in
order to save shield it's a moral
quandary see and we in the thirty so I
gotta do this see the episode opens with
Mac and deke pretending to be
bootleggers so that Fred doesn't get
onto the time-travel thing and little
did they know that he has the serum that
will help to return the power that he
and his family lost aboard the Zephyr
may has returned at the hibernation
chamber and she's getting flashbacks of
the season 6 finale in which she died
fighting the forces of eyes'll may
actually doesn't remember her own death
and as I said last week I have a feeling
that she might actually be possessed by
either isael or one of our allies and
though we don't get confirmation of this
in the episode it just seems so obvious
at this point she fights Enoch and even
manages to keep up with him at
hunter-killer Roboto Terminator 2
Judgment Day level so with all that's
going on it does seem quite obvious and
a person would be laid up in bed but may
healed really fast which could be seen
as simmered how Sarge was killed last
season and then he came back to life she
also asks how far away from home they
are and the delivery of this line
coupled with her saying she's hungry
it just seemed off to me a big
revelation doesn't surprise her as much
as it should and we'll get into this
later but obviously leave your comments
below and whether you agree with the
isael theory or not back at the
speakeasy Coulson and Daisy are trying
to heal up the mysterious lady in red
from last week apologies for our
previous breakdown as we thought that
she died but here she is indeed alive
and kicking after yoyo and Simmons show
up we get a nice little Star Trek nod in
which the latter says she's a doctor and
not a dame the character bones used to
do a play on this ever so often in the
show and if you look up the line there's
some really hilarious ones including I'm
a doctor not a moon shot conductor so
yeah I did appreciate the little line
here she manages to remove the bullet
and puts it in a shot nice the old gun
would play there and Daisy suggests
taking out Malik
Coulson shoots down this idea saying
that in doing so they would vastly
change the future and thus they decide
to go ahead with saving him and there's
a lot of back and forth over what the
right path to take is and Daisy actually
does something very out of character
towards the end speaking of out of
character I've noticed a lot of Simmons
is an LM d fan theories floating around
on language cently this is due to her
newfound impulsiveness forcing the
agents to travel through time on a whim
and just her general attitude Screen
Rant did a big article on this and
whilst I don't want to go over the
entire thing there are some notable
points that they dropped last week
Simmons refused to tell Daisy how much
time had passed to her and we know
they've been there awhile and this would
explain how Fitz and Simmons perfected
so much Andy chronic comm technology
just how long that is we don't know yet
but in order to appear the same Simmons
would need to have created an LM D in
order to not give anything away from her
physical appearance Fitz knows that the
chronic Combs can read minds and thus it
is possible that the pair created LMD
versions which would mean should they be
captured they'd be unable to find the
real version
he'll this Simmons doesn't even really
know where Fitz is so yeah some definite
evidence that adds weight to it being
the truth personally I'm still unsure as
I think her personality changes they
just kind of show how far the character
has come she's been through a lot with
the group and without them so this is
likely altered how she is it's all kind
of still up in the air but yeah either
one is definitely a possibility
elsewhere Freddie wants to hitch a ride
aboard a train and the krona cops show
up at the speakeasy while caning tries
to fend them off using his charm also
unnoticed a Greyhound painting which was
a nice little prop that hinted towards
the bootlegging greyhounds are of course
dogs that are fast runners and are often
used in gambling so this has slowly
become a symbol of smuggling there's
also an image of an old ship which too
is smoked never never mind I'm spending
far too much time on this anyway the
lady in the red dress wakes up and no
questioning leads nowhere Simmons who's
a biochemist and not a bird deduces that
she delivered the Super Soldier Serum
that would eventually create the Red
Skull
Eric's kind is also name-dropped and you
might remember him from the First
Avenger
Simmons notices that something's off
with the fluid just by looking at it
again so it does kind of make the lmd
theory seems slightly more legitimate on
the train Freddie talks about his past
in which he pretty much lost both his
parents after the Great Depression his
father jumped off a building and his
mother became a vegetable due to grief
Freddie did what he had to to survive
and this led to him smuggling the Super
Soldier Serum he also gets a really good
look at dekes radio and clearly
knowledge of how technology is heading
towards helps him to start reshape the
world in the future he pulls a gun on
the pair as the two start asking too
many questions and throughout this
episode you can slowly see him turning
to the dark side back on board the
Zephyr may Jukes it out with Enoch and
she's only stopped from killing him by
the appearance of Coulson this should
come as a real gut punch to her but she
doesn't even flinch hinting out what's
really going on with the character
Koenig is also shown the inside of the
ship which could add reason to why his
offspring eventually end up working so
high within shield Coulson pretty much
gives him the entire four on one on
everything
and thus he would likely steer his
children towards this in some ways he
was a father figure to Freddie who would
eventually go on to build Hydra so
perhaps he raised his own grandchildren
to counter this action Freddie deke and
Mack arrived at the drop-off point and
Daisy instructs deke to kill him again
this is completely out of character for
her and it seems like she's just
oblivious to how badly this would mess
up the timestream even in Avengers end
game after fudging things up cap
realized that it was paramount to keep
things the way that they were and he
returned everything to its correct place
except for himself
I really have to ding the episode for
this as it just seems like Daisy is not
seeing the bigger picture I think that
she would actually be one of the people
who would know protecting him was of the
utmost importance
luckily before Dee can do it the
Chronicles arrived and then Coulson and
Coe show up and drive bad [ __ ] I
cut her [ __ ] work because it's YouTube
in it I need that cash cash money you
know how it is
anyway the shootout is a great way to in
the episode and what is likely a final
time for our heroes in the days Freddie
bails and Kane again Enoch go on the
hunt for him whilst the time window
closes Freddie actually shoots Koenig
which shows how far down the dark path
he's willing to go I love that caning
says he just stepped off a building as
he leaves which is of course how his
father died so metaphorically the good
Freddie died in order to create Hydra
they weren't really saving him they were
pushing him towards a darker path and
yeah it's a nice how the subtext of the
show kind of tackles with this moral
ambiguity the time jump has to be
carried out and Enoch is left behind in
the 30s and whilst this does seem like
it may be the end for the character I
actually think that we will see him
again he's left to tend bar at the
speakeasy in the post-credits scene and
thus he will likely spend time helping
caning to get up to speed with the way
the world eventually turns whilst taking
the long way around to get back to the
agents of shield the speakeasy was of
course famous in the SSR and we get a
Casablanca as close to the scene with
caning stating that this looks like it's
gonna be the start of a marvelous
friendship as for the next time the
agents are heading to the 50s namely
area 51 where they will meet with Sousa
from aging
Carter quadrant Sousa had a sort of
fling but she just couldn't get that
star-spangled man with a plan out of her
head so who knows he might even end up
with Daisy I think it's gonna be a great
episode either way and I'm really on
board with how the seasons been so far
and there were only two episodes in so
it's a bit hard to judge but yeah so far
other than the Daisy thing I'm actually
quite enjoying it now obviously I loved
hear your thoughts on the second episode
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and if you
missed our analysis of the first episode
then make sure you check it out after
this you want to support the channel
from as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below every month we
give away free movies to be + subscribe
to the channel and this one T can win
the Marvel phase three party box set and
all you have to do is comment on a video
and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of June and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition it you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]